moi justement je tombe bien c'est
justement par l'état télévision avec de
vos vedettes préférées
tout d'abord les grandes émissions
médicales avec georges brassens
pourquoi sauter triste fardeau à voir
dans le bas du dos qui vous chante
accueil et à coller de rentes à paul
simon en colombie coliques un ppp pignan
néphrétique c'est que les calculs c'est
mon fort relais de rentes un style plus
territoire c'est qu'on analyse vient le
soir où votre tendre et les romains vous
offre son corps qu'elle attire à
l'ingénue qui pousse au feu s'éteint
mais mille regrets et gelé au nôtre les
deux mieux bapaume
et
à l'arrivée du de la course et des
tiercés l'interview du jockey charles
aznavour
la liste
incohérent prix j'étais plus lent des
plus grands jockeys genevriez j'aille
sur une belle pouliche donc les actes de
soins pour l'envers la joie les plus
grands succès largement il est jeune
qu'on bichonner chine dû me faire
jumeaux en galopant presque joue contre
joue car les sens venant avec malines
pour être premier c'est avec amour cosy
foulée coup j'étais impatient mont joli
emballage se sent la sueur coulait à
grands flots lourdes sont encore et
comme il se trouve aussi que je suis en
un jeune l'homme et l'animal mais
l'assumé tout avoué
tout ça n'est qu'un rêve j'ai des rimes
attise mais jamais un cheval la kolyma
voir aussi maintenant que l'on vit
jean clair je vais la voir
et je m'offre un tout je laisse bulls
et le calendrier de l'histoire une
partie de la révolution avec la rentrée
de jacques brel dans le rôle de camille
desmoulins emmenant louis saez et marie
antoinette au tribunal révolutionnaire
en chantant à fouquier tinville
je faisais importer les poires banc
car l'humour bon c'est périssable ils
ont mené tellement bourbon que pour
qu'ils soient y plus présentable
faudrait il coupait des soul man temps
je vous ai apporté les bobos et il nous
voilà sur la grande bleue à ce bien le
bonjour monsieur guillotin le serrurier
et certains vont sûrement faire la
grimace
tu entends dire ah bon pour le son je
faisais écourter les bourbons